und ich weiß ja nicht wie es ihnen geht
meine damen und herren aber ich bin
immer noch dabei
seelisch zu verarbeiten was diese woche
passiert ist oster ruhetage verordnet
und direkt wieder abgesagt was war das
denn meine das schiere ausmaß des
dilettantismus unfassbar wirklich
unfassbar welche chance haben wir so
gegen das virus
vielleicht muss man aber auch einsehen
wenn man verloren hat ernsthaft für mich
ist das was die letzten tage los war so
was wie die bedingungslose kapitulation
die britische mutante hat gewonnen
glückwunsch da sitzen also montagnacht
merkel und co virtuell zusammen und
erfinden spontan die oster ruhe ohne
vorher mit experten aus der wirtschaft
zu klären was da dran hängt an die
scheuer musste nachts lufthansa chefs
anrufen als wenn irgendwer angehen würde
mit andi ist nummer auf dem display
steht wie könnte man denn so ein fiasko
in zukunft vielleicht mal verhindern
wir fordern dass demnächst das nächste
zusammentreffen einmal morgens um 9 uhr
beginnt übermorgen beginnen statt am
späten nachmittag wenn man darf halt 14
uhr sitzt dann bis morgens um drei nicht
erst am abend um halb neun bis 3 uhr
nachts die dauer der zusammenkunft muss
im verhältnis stehen zu dem was hinten
rauskommt
schön das problem war aber nicht die
uhrzeit meine damen und herren
nächstes mal heißt es dann wir hatten
schon wieder keine durchdachten ideen
aber wir sind um 7 uhr aufgestanden toll
zwölf stunden haben die da verhandelt
davon sieben in kleineren exklusiven
runden bei denen aber offenbar nicht
jeder mitmachen durfte hier bodo ramelow
ist beleidigt bis 23.45 habe ich
überhaupt nicht gewusst wo die
bundeskanzlerin ist und wo ein teil der
ministerpräsidenten abgeblieben sind
ich habe dort sechs stunden vor dem
bildschirm gesessen und darauf gewartet
dass die viertelstunde pause um die
gebeten worden ist auch mal beendet wird
ich will gleich das war tatsächlich ein
klarer fall von mobbing die andere haben
gesagt wir treffen uns gleich in raum 2
aber ohne porto ja die kanzlerin kriegt
jetzt sehr viel respekt weil sie sich
bei uns allen entschuldigt hat keine
frage das ist immer gut und richtig
fehler zuzugeben
noch besser wäre allerdings eine idee
was denn jetzt stadt uster ruhe kommen
soll was zwölf stunden verhandlung und
am ende steht sie wollen die notbremse
die schon vor drei wochen beschlossen
wurde jetzt regelrecht an wänden und in
meinem auto müssen beifahrer aus einem
anderen haushalt ab sofort maske tragen
das ist es was ist denn los mit der
großen krisenmanagerin
vielleicht hätte man es ahnen können
meine größte stärke ist dass ich wenn es
nur tut dinge laufen lassen kann
schweigen kann und auf ende abwarten
kann
tja dann warten wir mal alle zusammen
auf sam klar schuld am aktuellen chaos
sind nicht zuletzt auch die länderchefs
aber nur termin shopping wieder
abschaffen wird die dritte welle nicht
aufhalten
nach allem was wir jetzt wissen also
entweder brauchen wir einen härteren
lockdown oder wir machen ganz
deutschland zu tübing also lockerungen
abgesichert mit technik und tests ein
konzept als schnell
okay wir halten fest oster ruhe klappt
nicht aber dafür haben die beteiligten
diese woche unglaublich viel gelernt
wie ist das mit den ostereiern die
ausgeliefert werden müssen und dann
nicht ankommen auch dafür gab es keine
antwort lieferketten unterbrochen sind
fleisch beispielsweise was an bestimmten
tagen soll lebensmittelversorgung da
sein muss babynahrung was ich
beispielsweise nicht wusste ja die babys
sind schuld weil diese egoisten ständig
irgendwas futtern müssen wirklich diese
ministerpräsident ist als format
offiziell gescheitert feierabend wie
immer wird an die wirtschaft an die
firmen appelliert mitarbeiter zu testen
echte einschränkungen gibt es nur bei
den bürgern im privaten selbst beim
österlichen abendmahl maximal ein
anderer haushalt erlaubt ja liebe kinder
diese ostern sollte oma und opa nicht
besuchen wegen kontakt reduzierung und
wenn der osterhase zu euch in den garten
hoppelt und seine eier zu verstecken
macht er sich leider strafbar weil er
ist
aus einem anderen haushalt und dann dann
greift das ordnungsamt ein
schade kollateralschäden nennt man das
fünf monate halbgare lockdown haben
unsere bevölkerung mürbe gemacht total
wirbel denn das ewige jetzt noch mal
drei wochen zähne zusammenbeißen dann
retten wir weihnachten oder wir wollen
doch alle ein schönes ostern
wahrscheinlich sollen wir als nächstes
den sommer retten
unser ziel ist es eben dass wir jetzt
noch mal so sagen das prinzip wir
bleiben zu hause ein stück praktizieren
damit im sommer wirklich gut wird nach
einem jahr pandemie setzen wir immer
noch auf dieselben steinzeit methoden
warum weil testen und impfen nicht aus
dem quark kommen immer noch nicht
großbritannien testet zehnmal mehr als
deutschland
auch deshalb werden wir hier am ende
natürlich an ausgangssperren nicht
vorbeikommen ist so und es wäre höchste
zeit dass uns bürgern trotz super war ja
mal ehrlich zu sagen hier markus söder
ist aus versehen ehrlich vorsicht
bedeutet das ist in zeitachsen definiert
bis ende oktober für wm gibt es keine
weitere öffnungen versprecher er meinte
natürlich osterferien hatte
weihnachtsferien ja dann stimmt's an der
infront beim impfen wird der kampf gegen
korona entschieden nicht auf mallorca
meldung aus dieser woche deutschlands im
tempo stagniert unter 300.000 dosen am
tag mein gott er irgendwann im april
impfens war auch die hausärzte mit jede
praxis kriegt aber nur 20 dosen pro
woche ich verlage endlich licht am ende
des tunnels es ist denkbar so sagen
jedenfalls wissen wissenschaftler das
ende des jahres mit einem impfstoff auch
gegen kinder gerechnet werden kann
immerhin der impfstoff gegen kinder
kommt für mich 20 jahre zu spät meinte
als nächstes scheitern wir garantiert
logistisch an zu viel impfstoff kommt
als nächstes glauben sie mir ernsthaft
wir müssen uns endlich mal eingestehen
dass wir es nicht mehr drauf haben
in diesem
regulierten land wir brauchen hilfe
sodass hier funktioniert nicht wenn es
versucht es geht nicht deshalb lieber du
lieber emanuel libero riss und herr
putin
wir brauchen eure hilfe die alliierten
müssen deutschland sofort wieder
übernehmen
nehmt einfach eure alten besatzungszonen
wir behalten nur mallorca denn eins ist
uns jetzt klar geworden
wir schaffen das oder aber auch nicht
eben drei von vier siegermächten ketten
impfstoff ich sag's nur wann schaltet
deutschland endlich in den katastrophen
modus pragmatisch zupackend
unbürokratisch so wie helmut schmidt
damals 62 bei der hamburger sturmflut
da fällt mir ein wir haben doch eine
bundesbehörde für katastrophenschutz
was macht ihr eigentlich deutschlands
vergessene behörden heute das bundesamt
für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe in bonn
abdel karim meldet sich live aus dem bbk
in bonn und in schwarz weiß ja weil die
zeit hier stehengeblieben ist alles noch
wie 1952 als der laden unter anderem
namen gegründet wurde
es macht sinn und die sind also
zuständig für katastrophen warum habe
ich von denen noch nie was gehört ja die
drängen sich halt nur sehr ungern in den
vordergrund dazu muss man wissen
katastrophenschutz ist in deutschland
und da kommen sie niemals drauf
grundsätzlich ländersache
bei katastrophen halten sich ja
bekanntlich streng an landesgrenzen
tatsächlich gibt es nur einen fall wo
der laden hier richtig aktiviert den
verteidigungsfall also wenn der russe
kommt jetzt ist der russe aber
hauptsächlich unser gas lieferant und
wenn es so weiter geht bald auch unser
impfstoff lieferant aha aber was machen
die denn da im bbk uns warnen vor
katastrophen und so wissen sie nicht
mehr
letztes jahr der große bundesweite
wahltag alle sirenen sollten
gleichzeitig drücken
leider können wir nicht mal mehr dass
der wahltag ging also dank kaum
vorhandener serien technik und schlecht
funktionierender digitaler warnung
diesmal ein großteil der bevölkerung
vorbei also wir haben nichts gehört
twitter scherzhaft der bund der
gehörlosen aber keine angst berlin
spendiert jetzt 88 millionen für neue
sirenen außerdem nach der blamage
letztes jahr ist der bka-chef ja direkt
rausgeflogen und sein nachfolger hat
große pläne
wir haben megatrends die sie schon
spüren wir monitoren ein best practice
verfahren zu entwickeln
drittens lessons learned wir sind ja
praktisch und troubleshooting zu unseren
lösung gekommen ein cockpit anbieten
ich glaube dass die kompetenz des bbk
hat sie noch nicht jedem erschlossen
ja das glaube ich auch sagen sie könnten
die uns denn mit irgendwas helfen in
dieser pandemie
ja klar die übernehmen demnächst bitte
jetzt festhalten das sogenannte
monitoring für schutzkleidung das heißt
sie schreiben auf wieviel schutzkleidung
in welchem bundesland rumliegt das wurde
bis jetzt noch nicht gemacht dass wir
quasi geheimnisverrat wenn das der russe
mitkriegt ich gebe zu die behörde hier
ist ein bisschen aus der zeit gefallen
sieht man auch an dem image
den sie wohlgemerkt im jahr 2019 über
sich und ihr wappentier den kranich
gemacht haben wer kann ich stehen für
wachsamkeit
in meiner klaue halte ich einen stein
sollte ich einschlafen und den stein
loslassen dann wird mich das geräusch
des aufpralls wecken
da war ich kurz eingenickt aber hey das
wär doch die lösung wenn alle im
kabinett merkel ständigen stein in der
hand haben dann sind wir spätestens bei
der übernächsten pandemie hellwach so
und jetzt werden hier die neuen sirenen
getestet
[Musik]
abdel karim
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liebt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]